I like Kevin said I'm going to talk
about modern startup financing I have
only been practicing law for 21 years so
what's old and what's new
only spans that timeframe for me but
I've seen a lot of changes to the
startup ecosystem YC has been a big part
a lot of a lot of the changes to the
startup ecosystem in the way that
financing is done so I picked this
picture these are called closing volumes
and every corporate lawyer who does
private company you're a public company
financing has a lot of these if they
have been doing it for long enough the
legal teams used to get these bound
volumes with all of the financing
documents in them they have our names on
them and the date and so this doesn't
happen anymore but I just thought this
was I saves in my mind I thought this
was a good picture for this so a lot of
you are gonna already know what I'm
about to talk about but since this is
startup school I just want to give some
basics so you have a company idea and
the first thing you're gonna do is form
a corporation because it's a separate
legal entity and it protects the
founders from personal liability right
we all know this
you can probably bootstrap it you and
your co-founders can bootstrap it for a
little while but eventually you're going
to want to hire or grow and you need
money to do that how do you do that you
can go ask your relatives for money you
can go to a bank and ask for a loan or
but most startups do is they sell a part
of their company to raise money so when
you as founders you guys will buy common
stock that's how you become owners of
your corporation and typically you will
buy a common stock for fraction of a
penny you may contribute some
intellectual property as part of that
purchase but basically you're going to
be buying your stock and own a hundred
percent of it for nothing you cannot
raise a meaningful amount of money by
selling common stock so your option is
to sell to investors a completely
different class of stock called
preferred stock
preferred stock is more expensive before
another kind of basic thing I never know
what the you know what kind of
terminology people know so I thought
it'd be really helpful to take a look at
this these terms right here so first of
all financing and round they mean
exactly the same thing preferred equity
financing preferred stock round
preferred stock financing series a
financing series seed financing these
things all basically mean the same thing
its fundraising by selling preferred
stock at a calculated specific price per
share these terms
convertible rail note round safe
financing we're gonna talk about what
the safe is early stage around
early-stage financing these are all ways
to describe a fundraising event where
you're not selling preferred stock or
coma stock you're selling convertible
securities convertible securities are
the right to get stock in the future
it's a thing that it's not itself stock
it converts into stock later so I think
that there are about three things that
have changed a lot over the years and
the first one is structure and by that I
just mean that the actual document that
we use for early stage fundraising has
changed and I'm going to talk about that
more in a few slides the other thing
that is hugely different from the old
days is access because nowadays you can
find fundraising documents online and
you know they come with annotations and
these signatures and it's just
incredibly easy to get documents back in
the olden days the only way you could
fundraise was by hiring a lawyer because
there was no way to get the documents
you actually needed to sell your
preferred stock and the other thing that
I think has changed a lot over the years
is focus I just remember I don't ever
remember anybody ever noticing how much
time it took to do these financings in
the past and how much focus it took away
from founders building their company
like I don't remember an investor or a
founder
my gosh this is taking a month and a
half I'd so much rather be building my
company I think today people notice and
have figured out that it's not in
anyone's best interest for people to be
spending a lot of time fundraising so
it's much faster so what hasn't changed
preferred stock financings are no longer
the way that companies raised their
first do their first fund raising but
that process and those documents
themselves really haven't changed over
the years and I'll talk about that a
little bit more in a second but that's
pretty much the same it's just the wind
that's changed the other thing that
hasn't really changed as I think there
are two things that are super important
to investors and to founders when
they're fundraising and those two things
are valuation and dilution so valuation
is just the value of your enterprise and
I Lucien is stock like how much you know
how much of your company have you sold
so if you are selling investors a
percentage of your company you
previously owned 100% of it after you
sell them you're not gonna own 100% of
it
that's dilution and then the last thing
I just really wanted to add in here
because I think it's really important to
get this point across to people who are
starting startups communication with
investors has always been important
because this is fundamentally about a
relationship right investors are giving
you money and you are being expected to
take their money and turn it into a
billion dollar business whether or not
you are succeeding or failing at that
endeavor is so critical to communicate
with your investors about that so I
think that that's something that has not
changed over the years it's still super
important to communicate so as I
mentioned before the old way of raising
early money was to do a series a
preferred stock financing a is the first
letter of the alphabet so the first time
that a start-up would fundraise it would
be called a series a preferred stock
financing okay how did it work so we
take the valuation of your company which
is the overall value of your enterprise
you would divide it by the number of
outstanding shares of
but I'll stock that's mostly for a
series a financing just be the stuff
that the founders owned and that gets
you a price per share you'd take that
price per share and you would sell your
preferred stock to your investors so now
bull back then angel investors you I'm
sure you guys have heard about angel
investors they used to aggregate into
consortiums and so they would tend to
all band together and write one big
check so for your series a financing you
would have maybe a couple of angel
groups and you would raise about 1.5 to
2 million dollars in your series a
preferred stock roan angel groups now a
right individual checks doesn't really
happen like in consortiums anymore
anyway then you would negotiate the
terms of the preferred stock so the lead
investor and you the company would have
you each get your own legal counsel the
lawyers would go back and forth they
would negotiate the terms of the
preferred stock which means voting
rights liquidation rights pro-rata
rights and then you'd end up with a set
of documents that go in those closing
volumes and there is you know there's
about five of them this took months and
it was could cost anywhere in legal fees
from twenty five to one hundred thousand
dollars okay so what's broken about that
well that's pretty elaborate right takes
a long time it costs I just told you it
could cost you know twenty-five to 100k
on legal fees to do this so it's kind of
a big deal but I think that the thing
that was most broken about it was how
inflexible it was
Gerry's plug in a touch on this it used
that the cost of starting a company has
decreased a ton over the years not so
much for software and e-commerce
companies I'm sorry
not so much for hard tech companies but
software edan ecommerce companies the
price of actually starting these
startups has way decreased and as a
result companies actually don't need to
raise
one point five to two million dollars
just to get off the ground and having to
do these long elaborate expensive
financings was not worth it so it would
just wasn't at all flexible so when a
company would do a big series a round
for its first round and then it was
waiting to do its series be financing
sometimes it would run out of money in
between and so oftentimes the company
would then go to its lead finance that's
lead investor rather in the in their
series a financing and they would ask
for a bridge loan a bridge loan is a
debt bridge between two financings and
these involve the no purchase agreement
and a convertible promissory note and
sometimes there would be common stock
warrants that would go with it but
basically it was a stopgap measure in
between financing so again keep in mind
these finance things I just told you
were long and expensive so you aren't
just doing them all the time and this is
where bridge loan financing came in at
the heart of the of the bridge alone was
this convertible promissory note and a
convertible promissory note was a loan
it had an interest rate it had a
maturity date it was a real note but it
also had a mechanic that would cause it
to automatically convert into shares of
stock when you did that next round so if
you got a bridge loan in between your
Series A in your Series B your
convertible promissory notes would
convert into shares of series be when
that financing happened but along the
way and I honestly don't remember how
this all came about but people started
to realize that just the convertible
promissory note not necessarily the no
purchase agreement or the Comstock
warrants but the convertible promissory
note itself could actually be used as a
standalone document and you could use it
to fund companies and you could use it
to fund not as a bridge but actually
just the very first time that a company
needed money so this became a very
appealing way to do your first
fundraising event because instead of
having all those documents I described
in this series a financing instead you
just had a convertible promissory note
which was obviously going to be a lot
faster it's only one document used
people still hired lawyers for these
convertible notes but only negotiating
one document and your only negotiating
maybe maturity date and interest rate
lots cheaper and lots more flexible
because now instead of being you know
having to do this elaborate financing
process and probably wanting to raise a
couple million dollars to justify all
that effort you could just raise 50k
from an angel you could raise a hundred
K from an angel or even less but it's
still a promissory note and a promissory
note is still alone so it's debt we then
at YC decided that we could modernize
even the convertible promissory note and
what we did is we came up with something
called the safe the safe is an acronym
it stands for simple agreement for
future equity unlike the promissory note
it is one simple document it is a
convertible security so we went I showed
you all those terms it's a convertible
security it converts into stock when the
company raises a priced round you don't
need to hire lawyers to do a safe it's
available online and the most important
part of it is that it isn't debt which
is why it needed to exist what was
broken about convertible promissory
notes they were only one document they
were cheap they were fast well because
we didn't think it made any sense to use
debt to sell equity angel investors are
not lenders and startups don't really
want to be borrowers right the whole
point of taking someone's 50k and
turning it into a billion dollars is
everybody that those investors want to
be stockholders and startups don't want
to be thinking about accruing interest
or you know when is their note gonna be
due so we thought that it made a lot
more sense to take all the debt peace
all the debt part out of convertible
promissory notes but retain all of the
the convenience of them so I could do an
entire lecture on how to use the safe
and what it's all about but I've
actually already done that so there are
other startup school video lectures that
you guys can watch to hear a ton more
about the safe the this is the
this is the YC page this is the
resources tab so say finance and
documents at the top we have a user
guide that is kind of long but it has a
ton of really good information and it
tons of math examples to use to show you
how it converts so please visit that
then the safe is only five pages long
has the word simple in it right it's
actually really easy to read so then the
question is when do priced rounds happen
they are still the primary way that
startups raise money they're no longer
the way that most startups raise they're
do their first fundraising but builds
into the safe and other convertible
securities like promissory notes is the
whole concept that eventually the
company's going to do a priced round and
those convertible securities are going
to convert into that price round so most
often companies will do their first
fundraising on a safe convertible
promissory note and then they will do a
price surround afterward and all of
those safes and convertible promissory
notes will convert into stock safes in
convertible from Disturbed's cannot
convert unless there is a price run done
eventually so so price rounds are still
modern they're just not the modern way
to raise your money the first time and
also I should mention priced rounds even
though it's kind of laughing at them
because they are involved a lot of
documents and we used to put them in
these leather-bound closing volumes for
the lawyers to put on their bookshelves
they have actually seen some
improvements as well they are much more
standard than they used to be and they
are also all five of the price round
documents you can get them online these
days you still everyone tends to still
hire a lawyer for them but ok so did we
perfect modern early stage financing by
use it by by introducing a safe and by
you know everybody using convertible
securities to raise money the first time
and I would say come a long way but I
don't think it's quite perfected and the
reason is because I mentioned dilution a
few minutes ago so convertible
securities because people who hold
investors that hold convertible
securities are not stock holders you
actually don't it's very hard to tell
how much ownership of your company you
have sold when you saw a sell a
convertible security they're not
your cap table of stockholders right
you're still a hundred percent owner if
all you've ever done is sell convertible
securities but the day of reckoning is
coming when you do your price round and
they all all those convertible
securities convert into shares of stock
you have to keep track and there are a
ton of resources and tools on how you
can keep track but you got to do the
work there's no excuse for being
surprised by realizing you sold 30
percent of your company top to all of
your angel investors so so don't let
that happen to you the other thing that
has that is a little to be aware of with
early-stage fund raising using
convertible securities is because it's
so flexible and easy to raise custom
amounts of money you know you can raise
100k and decide that you could bootstrap
on that for a while and then maybe in a
couple months to raise 50k because you
just need a little bit more it's very
flexible but you can end up with a ton
of investors and we call that a party
round right used to be that in the old
days you'd maybe have six to ten
investors and now you can have you know
25 35 different angel investors who've
given you money that's great
you got the money it's not a bad thing
but it can be administrative leery aliy
challenging because they become
stockholders when you do a price round
and then you need their consent because
you know corporations have stockholder
consents kind of hard to chase down all
those signatures again not a bad thing
just something you got to be aware of
and finally one of the side effects of
these convertible rounds is that
investors write smaller checks they tend
to and they don't care as much about the
investor not stockholders yet so they're
not quite as invested this is a
double-edged sword
sometimes investors can drive you insane
but sometimes they can be really helpful
right they will make introductions for
you they'll help you with strategic
advice so having investors who've just
written a check and got into convertible
security as opposed to writing a really
big check and being a stockholder it can
mean the difference between how much
attention they pay to you again can be
good can be bad but it's just a side
effect this is my summary slide okay
so modern early stage rounds of
financing are usually done now using
convertible securities like the safe
selling preferred stock and priced
rounds is still modern it still happens
it has to happen it just tends to happen
later it tends to be your second
fundraising not your first the whole
point as I said before is focus if you
don't have to spend a lot of time
negotiating documents if you can get the
money in the bank really fast you can go
back to building your company which is
what you want it's what your investors
want is specifically for this crowd this
is not San Francisco this is Boston
what safes and convertible securities
are completely common on the west coast
I suspect that you guys will find angel
investors and other people in your
ecosystem out here that are less
familiar with doing finance things this
way so maybe a little bit of education
involved you may have investors who say
no I don't I've never heard of this safe
I want to do convertible promissory note
or you may have investors are just like
what are you talking about I don't do
convertible securities I'm buying
preferred stock that's what we're doing
if you want my money kind of hard to say
outside of the Silicon Valley but for
the most part I would recommend that you
approach fundraising with this idea of
doing convertible securities just
because it can be done so fast and so
flexibly and that is it
do you want me to do questions ok how
many a few ok yes so I do not think I
repeat the quotas long
ok so if you take small checks from
angel investors to do your early
fundraising do VC's look at that in a
negative light when you go to them to do
your priced round I would say no that is
they don't
I mean you've you you've taken small
amounts of money you've gotten X far
right like you've hit all these
milestones or now go into these season
saying please do my priced round I think
the fact that you raise money from
angels and took some small checks just
shows how focused you were on getting
through that process fast and iterating
and getting to the place where you can
do a price round yeah maybe building a
little off a smaller check but do you
ever recommend something like equity
crowdfunding so like yeah so great
question you know I thought that was
super and just since I've been
practicing for 21 years like that's a
huge change right and oh I'm sorry yeah
ok he was running about crowdfunding so
they changed the sec changed the rules
you can now you can now actually
generally solicit and have your company
be crowd funded where actual strangers
can buy your equity it has a lot of
rules and regulations around it if you
like it's still in the testing phase
like no YC company to my knowledge has
done that yet so I don't have any
personal experience with it Mike died
but I know some companies have done it
and they would be really interesting to
go online and see if you can get like
like download from law firms that have
helped with those crowdfunding
initiatives to see kind of what the pros
and cons were
okay yeah so according to the current
state what happens if the company does
the following
okay so that's a great question so so he
is wondering what happens if you never
do a price around you've ich you've sold
a bunch of safes to investors this safe
only converts in the event that you
raise a price round your company gets
sold or you go public and there is
absolutely this concept that well what
if my company just putters along and
never needs to raise any more money that
is what I call a corner case and my
whole point in drafting the safe was to
keep it simple so I specifically did not
try to capture every corner case that's
out there it is exceedingly rare for a
company to be able to take a tiny amount
of money that it raises from its safe
holders and then go on and never need to
nothing couldn't happen but it's pretty
rare there's going to being a liquid I
mean the founders want liquidity too
right so how are the founders ever gonna
get liquidity if they don't sell or go
public or you know raise more money so
yes of course and and some you you will
surely meet some investors who raise
that exact point well you know with
promissory notes at least it was debt it
could be repaid they knew they were
gonna get their money back that's not
true with the safe but again it is like
it's a gamble it's like investor do you
want to buy a piece of my company this
is how you can do it and and if you
don't believe that I'm ever gonna raise
money again or that I'm ever gonna do
anything with this company then maybe
it's not the right investment you know
so that's there's a million different
ways you can respond to that but
basically in all my years of practice I
only ever had one client that had only
raised one round like it just companies
need more money to grow it's kind of the
way I look at it way in the back
[Music]
okay what's the threshold from how do
you know which convertible security or
should you do a price around how do you
know basically what your what to do I'm
glad you asked that question because I
did I wanted to make this point and
forgot if a VC wants to give you five
million dollars as your very first fund
raise do it it's like I'm not sitting
here saying like you should never do a
price round for your first fundraising
event absolutely so if someone wants you
to do a price round and it makes sense
for your company valuation why's
dilution why's money raising why's do it
otherwise it does not matter how much
you're raising on convertible securities
it's about what you're comfortable with
and it's about tracking dilution right
how much are you actually selling we had
a YC company that did a 50 million
dollar safe and I almost choked because
I was like I I didn't build it for that
you know it's a very simple document
like it made me nervous thinking about
it but it's fine
it worked it's fine so it kind of
depends on what your investors want to
do with you again like you need their
money so if they really really want to
do convertible promissory notes and
that's how you're gonna get to the next
milestone and you need that money take
it right it's better than dying but you
know should you not do save just because
someone wants to do a five hundred
thousand do a five hundred thousand
dollars if it's fine just again
track the dilution yeah oh I'm glad you
asked that again this is all in that
other lecture but but because you asked
he wanted to know what the key terms of
the safe are valuation that's it that's
the only thing you have to negotiate in
a safe so and that's probably I mean
it's not an insignificant thing right
you and your investor have to decide
what valuation you're going to plop into
the safe as your target valuation and
that's going to place into the math
about how it converts and that plays
into dilution too so
you have to figure that out and there we
do have a version of the safe if you go
to the resources tab you can see all
these we do have a version of the safe
that doesn't actually even have a
valuation in there so in theory you
could even get away with not even
negotiating a valuation with your
investors and you could try it that way
so then so that's an option but freely
that's the only thing you need to
negotiate and like I said no lawyers
because what do you need them for okay
so so this person's investor is saying
let's add something to the safe that
that will address the issue of what if
you never do a price round in my safe
never converts so sure if that's the way
you can get the money from this person
and you really want this person's money
and you need to do it that's fine you
know with the convertible promissory
notes used to do is they would have a
term sheet attached to them as an
exhibit and at the maturity date the
company hadn't already gotten a priced
round put together with a new lead
investor that money would automatically
convert on the terms that were
negotiated on that term sheet that
that's our route I could have taken with
the safe but honestly that's just more
stuff to negotiate and I didn't want
that to be part of the safe so that's
not but if your investor said let's just
put let's just have this automatic
conversion event here are the terms you
can totally do that
two more questions okay anyone else yes
okay so his question was what if you
wanted to give basically you're saying
what if I want to give someone equity
for services rendered because I don't
want to give them cash okay so the safe
is a weird instrument to do to use for
that because the safe is fundamentally
like give me the money upfront I'll give
you the stock later if you're not
getting any money if you're saying
basically I'm getting my services and
I'm just going to give you stuff I mean
I probably
that's probably not the way I would
handle it better to try to get money
yeah probably I mean it yeah I don't
really think of the safe as being the
thing you can use to me like what you're
talking about is how do I get really
cheap founder likes talk to someone
who's done a favor for me and I wouldn't
use the safe for that I think there's
other ways you can do that and and am I
allowed to say we're doing an AMA on
Friday like these kinds of questions
we're gonna do an AMA am I actually
gonna have my other YC legal team with
me and we can answer questions like that
and give you a little few more ideas but
probably not the safe for that just to
answer your question okay it's anyone
anyone else we all good all right
[Applause]
you